[Music]
bleed or not comic-con isn't the only
thing going on this week the Republican
National Convention is also happening in
Cleveland yeah are there a lot of fans
here in honor of both conventions
happening at the same time we thought
it'd be fun to bring out someone who
represents both comic-con and the
Republican Party he's here tonight
please welcome captain make America
great again
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks coded I've waited a very long
time to be here I have to tell you we're
all thrilled to have you captain make
America great again yeah agreed Koda now
listen booking me is gonna be huge for
America which needs my super powers now
more than ever
okay I'm sorry what exactly are your
super powers
well I have all the best super powers go
tonight believe me I know super power
okay I just didn't know you had any
secret powers I'm not sure about that
look look look look this city needs me
all right I was walking around San Diego
today and frankly this place is a dump
[Music]
thank you wow it's overrun it's overrun
with rookies zombies and Klingons
yes yes so that's supposed to be its
comic-con well let me say this all right
that klieg on planet they're not sending
us their best all right
oh it's true we're getting great
Klingon now we're not drug-dealing
Klingon so if they all seem very very
angry and none of them speak English
that's that's it everything you just
said it's very offensive don't eat going
I am going to build a wall between all
the planets and I will make the aliens
paper that's not no just you should go I
think you should go your views are not
welcome here I will make San Diego and
America great again
[Music]
hail Hydra
[Applause]
[Music]
you